at the end of the day I think people
just want someone who's normal honest
practical and capable that's that's what
they want and when you look at that
criteria you you don't Donald Trump
doesn't fit the bill and Joe Biden in
most respects doesn't fit the bill
five-term Michigan congressman Justin
Amash has announced that he's running
for the libertarian party's presidential
nomination which will be decided in late
May the 40 year-old son of
middle-eastern immigrants took office in
2011 as a Republican but left the party
last July saying he didn't want to be
part of a partisan death spiral his
consistently voted against corporate
bailouts increases in debt finance
government spending overseas military
interventions and the prosecution of the
federal drug war during the corona virus
pandemic Amash has castigated federal
agencies such as the CDC and FDA first
for botching containment efforts and
then for asserting monopoly control over
testing he was one of a mere handful of
no votes on the 2.2 trillion dollar care
Zack arguing that all relief payments
should go directly to individuals and
households rather than corporations
nonprofits or government agencies we
intend to win this race I mean it's not
a race for fun as I've said many times
Republican and Democratic loyalists are
lashing out at Amash as a quixotic
potential spoiler with no chance of
being elected and calling for him to
step aside we do not have room for error
in this election this is no time for a
Ross Perot or a Jill Stein or a Ralph
Nader third party candidates always a
pain in the butt now but I think that
Amash is going to hurt the Republicans
more than the Democrats it 100% helps
Trump hurts Biden I talked with a mosh
over Skype about why he thinks Donald
Trump is too erratic to be given a
second term why Joe Biden is too old for
a first term and why he believes his
vision of a freer country will take him
to victory in November Congressman Amash
thanks for talking to Reason thanks for
having me on Nick okay so let's get
right to it why are you running for
president as a libertarian well I'm
running for president because I think we
need an alternative
these two candidates and we need someone
in Washington who's going to be honest
and practical and respect the rights of
the people and fight for a system that
will benefit the people so what is
what's your vision of the country that
and I'm sorry to chop you out there
because you know you're talking about
fairness and competency but then you
know in broader terms you know what what
is the country you want to live in I
want to live in a country where people
feel they have freedom to make decisions
for their own lives and where people
live respectfully with one another so if
someone has a difference of opinion
someone has a different perspective on
how things might work we can all live
together and and we don't all have to
have the same exact rules from community
community that's why we have a system of
federalism different people can live in
different places and make different
choices about their lives and I think
that's the system the founders really
intended and we've perfected that over
the years we've perfected the system so
we actually have at least under our
Constitution more freedoms more
protections today for the people to make
decisions for themselves yet at the same
time we have a government that has been
moving in the other direction in recent
decades because of how they run the
system where they've been consolidating
power and just a few people and taking
away representation and moving more and
more to the federal government and away
from state governments local governments
and individuals let's talk about that
more broadly in a second but right now
you know everybody I mean the reason
we're doing this the way we are is
because of the corona virus pandemic and
the state and federal responses to it
what and I think in talking about this
it'll it'll illuminate your larger you
know ideas about government but what is
the single biggest mistake that Donald
Trump has made and the federal
government has made and these are
separate things in combating or
confronting the novel coronavirus
pandemic they were very slow right from
the get-go in terms of getting testing
finding the the individuals who have the
initial cases and we don't know exactly
when that happened either there are some
evidence that that maybe it started
earlier
in the States than we realize but there
wasn't enough of an effort when we first
heard about it coming out of China to
find those cases and also get the
testing ramped up really quickly
so that people could be tested we could
contain it and and part of that is a
regulatory issue just the the the FDA
and the CDC getting in the way of the
ability of private labs to actually get
the tests out there right and I you know
that's what they exist for and they were
not prepared and then getting in the way
what about you know and that's kind of
the long-term government you know these
are lifers it's not political appointees
what has Trump done that you think is
either right or wrong in his in the way
that he's kind of responded to things I
think his instincts about the way the
power should be split up is probably
right
he has some instincts about the federal
government not managing everything at
the top he conveys it in totally the
wrong way and he vacillates from day to
day so one day he'll say he has ultimate
authority and he controls the whole
thing I don't know if he's trying to
appeal to some group or own someone with
that kind of statement or what he's
trying to do but then the next day he'll
go back to the states should handle
things
he's vacillated but in some sense I
think he probably has some instincts
that are right about this that one
person or one small group of people
sitting at a table can't make all these
determinations that you have to divide
the the process and you have to use the
knowledge that's at home but that's both
a-you know he's been both good and bad
in the sense that like I said he
vacillates one day he'll say he has
ultimate power and controls everything
the next day he'll say which i think is
probably closer to his instincts to say
that we need to divide this up a little
bit you know you have been critical of
your governor in Michigan governor went
mirror what would you do differently if
you were president or if you were
governor of your specific state so
setting aside for now the relief package
is I think the relief package is a whole
other issue yeah I would be very clear
about the division of powers in our
system and very clear that the White
House is there to coordinate things it's
there to provide guidance it's there to
provide assistance it's there to help
when there aren't sufficient resources
so some states might have a massive
surge like New York and the state might
need resources that it can't obtain
quickly the federal government might
step up in that circumstance whereas for
some other states maybe there's not the
same need because you know it might be
some state out in the Mountain West or
something where they don't have the same
immediate need for the federal
government to step in so this the
federal government would be there to
assist and provide guidance as for how
state governments should operate state
governments obviously have more
authority to shut things down
well like tell businesses they're not
going to operate etc then the federal
government does but you have to be
mindful of the way people react to it so
if I were a state governor which I'm not
running for to be clear if I were a
state governor I would give communities
particularly counties for example in the
state of Michigan more authority to make
decisions along with the cities in those
counties like I live near the city of
Grand Rapids and you might give those
counties and cities more authority to
make decisions about how to allocate
resources and handle the virus in the
particular community because there's a
big difference between say what's
happening on the east side of the state
and what's happening on the west side of
the state and some of the rules you put
in place on the east side of the state
might not make a lot of sense on the
west side of the state and might
actually lead to more deaths and more
economic devastation than then would
otherwise happen if you just allowed
people to make decisions at home from a
public health perspective do you think
we have overreacted to the problem so
far it's hard to say whether we've
overreacted in the sense that it is a
big issue we don't know what will happen
with the virus so at first you have to
take some pretty extraordinary measures
but a lot of these measures can be taken
by society I'm not sure that they all
have to be compelled by government
that's that's a big difference between
my approach and maybe some of these
governor's approaches where I would say
you can make more decisions at home and
there's a lot of reasons to think that
people would make voluntarily the right
decisions there's actually data on this
showing that many people would just make
the right decisions in these
circumstances I I'm sure governor's
nudging it along does also help but you
you want to get people the the most room
possible
we've overreacted in some ways and maybe
under acted in other ways so well let's
talk about the the cares Act you the 2.2
trillion dollar spending bill passed you
know a few weeks ago by Congress you
were one of the few people who were
public in Congress who was publicly on
the record as saying no you actually
entered a no vote even though it had
been done by a voice vote what is the
essential mistake that is being made by
the way that the the federal government
economically is dealing with it with the
you know economic collapse caused by the
shutdown of the economy it's pretty
simple when you have a crisis like this
the keys to get assistance to people who
need it the most as fast as possible
it's it's that simple you don't spend
time weeks and weeks like they did
coming up with a convoluted scheme and
negotiating it back and forth about well
we want this enhancement and we want
this change and we want this provision
and we want these restrictions and we
want these other you know guidelines and
other your you've made it too
complicated for people and you slow the
process down so that by the time they
get the assistance they need it's
already too late they're already in
trouble and what happened with this
coronavirus relief package is the
massive pot of corporate welfare the
five hundred billion dollars for the
Federal Reserve that went out pretty
quickly that you know cuz the Federal
Reserve and minuchin they can get that
stuff out quickly to the big
corporations and then this convoluted
scheme at the bottom with PPP and
enhanced unemployment benefits etc huh
it's very slow I have constituents right
now who cannot get the unemployment
benefits they need
I have small businesses in my community
they cannot get the loans they need the
resources they need so they're they're
struggling right now they have to go to
food banks
other things and they could have had
assistants very quickly and it could
have been done at a lower cost than what
we spent which is up to now about three
trillion dollars I would guess no so
what uh what would you say it's Donald
Trump's biggest failure as president and
what do you fear most from a second term
of Donald Trump well there are lots of
policy failures for example he talked
about getting us out of the wars he
didn't get us out of the wars I mean
it's always like next week we're going
to do something or we're coming up with
some deal with someone and it'll happen
sometime in the future so there's a lot
of talk a talk of that kind of stuff you
see him talk about FISA of course
because of what happened and with
respect to his campaign and and with
respect to the Russia investigation but
then when it comes to the legislation
that comes through where we try to
reform FISA he hasn't been helpful in
any way really with respect to revisor
reform and you're getting the same stuff
brought over and over again and and he's
putting a stamp on it and signing the
legislation to continue the same kind of
surveillance laws that have violated our
privacy look at civil asset forfeiture -
another example where he's continued the
civil asset forfeiture process and
actually enhanced it where you have
federal adoptive forfeiture is happening
so there are I could go policy after
policy and Donald Trump in most respect
is in as is an establishment Republican
he's he essentially merged with a Mitch
McConnell at some point he took his
rhetoric and his style and merged it
with Mitch McConnell's policies and
that's what you have now that's
basically the Republican Party it's
terrifying apparitions
it's basically Mitch McConnell's policy
with Donald Trump's style and that's
today's Republican Party which is a
frightening combination yeah what do you
fear most in a second term is does he
take us finally over the fiscal cliff
that seems to be in the in the immediate
future but we haven't yet reached or
yeah what yeah I didn't even mention
this the the spending and all that you
know even when the economy was good he
kept signing these spending bills and
said the debt doesn't matter that Efes
it doesn't matter
so I do see us going
cliff I don't think that the president
cares at all about the deficit or death
I think he'll just keep running it up
what he cares about is re-election his
ego people loving him that kind of thing
and anything to get him to that point
where where he has adoration or he gets
enough of the percentage of the vote to
win that's that's what he cares about so
you've said that you know talking about
Donald Trump switching to Joe Biden
you've said that Joe Biden is not up to
it meaning the job of being president
what do you mean by that
and what is your assessment Biden you
know Biden was in the Senate basically
longer than you've been alive he was a
vice president for eight years you know
what is what is your knock on Joe Biden
well there are lots of things to
criticize here but I do think that he's
had his opportunity he's run twice for
president he's had a long career in
politics I don't think the time to
become president is when we've got
Donald Trump in office and then you're
running in your 7778 years old or
whatever he is at this point and you're
going to turn 80 during your term he I
think is not at the prime of his career
to be able to handle a job of that kind
of pressure and you know my dad's 80
years old we all have older parents and
grandparents and others we know that it
becomes difficult as they get older to
to manage something like being the head
of the executive branch so you want to
have someone who's more in their prime
and I think that I think that matters
and when you look at when you look at
Biden's policies he's been all over the
board throughout his career but he's
pushed for some of the most anti Liberty
policies that we know about I mean
whether name names couple of those yeah
whether it's an expansion of federal
criminalization he was at the forefront
of that for many years it with respect
to privacy laws he was pushing for
programs and other surveillance laws
that eventually evolved into things like
the Patriot Act and FISA
he's been terrible on corporate welfare
and in a variety of corporate issues
over the years giving more power to
corporations at the expense of people so
there's a long list of things you could
go through with Joe Biden where he has
been essentially an establishment
Democrats lash Republican I mean they're
not that far off in many respects on
some of these major policies and that's
not really what we need right now if you
go back to the status quo you're going
to end up with another Donald Trump if
you revert to you know the pre Donald
Trump Republican versus Democratic
battles you're just going to get another
Donald Trump because the people are not
happy with this system it doesn't
represent them and they're going to rise
up again and it might be a democratic
Donald Trump or it might be a Republican
Donald Trump but you'll get another one
you know Biden was obviously part of the
Obama administration which gave us
health care reform health care where is
more important now than ever because of
coronavirus how what is your assessment
of Obama care at the time you were a
staunch opponent where are we now in
terms of health care and how would you
reform healthcare spending or or the
insurance system well I think you can
have some sort of government backstop
but it should be handled at the state
level not at the federal level so you
mostly want to have a private market and
then you want to have some kind of
backstop for people who don't have
proper coverage and that might be some
kind of expansion of a medicaid style
system or something like that that's
handled at the state level and gives
people the assurance that when things
aren't going well for them and they need
some health care and they don't have the
insurance to cover it there will be
someone to cover it but when you do
things like that it meets be understood
that the government will have to make
decisions about what's covered and
what's not because if you set it up so
that it covers every single thing under
the Sun no matter what the cost will go
through the roof because there's no
there's no limit on that if you don't
have private actors Donald Trump excuse
me Trump and Biden of both think
credibly accused of sexual assault can
you state definitively that you have
never assaulted anyone or acted
improperly toward them and and how do
you balance concern for victims with
concerns for due process of the accused
yes I can say that definitively and I
think it's important that everyone have
due process in other words if the
accusation is made you can't just say
the person is guilty without a trial and
a proper intervention and all that you
can't just rush to judgment on it
because accusations can be made that are
false and we should be willing to
acknowledge that at the same time when
someone makes an accusation I think we
should not rush to judgment about the
accuser because it very well could be a
real situation where the person was
harmed and we should respect people who
are making the accusation and give them
the full opportunity to make their case
and to present evidence and and have
that evidence corroborated do you think
if Joe Biden is guilty of you know
digitally penetrating Tara Reid that
disqualifies him from running for
president or holding public office I
think anyone is disqualified if they've
engaged in some kind of assault like
especially a sexual assault so so I
think that's disqualifying but for my
part on this campaign I'm focused on
other issues and and I think that needs
to be sorted out but it will be sorted
out through the media and through the
the parties involved foreign policy I
mean you've raised it a couple times
already Donald Trump had talked a good
game about getting a set of dumb Wars
for overseas wards foreign policy and
military intervention has faded a bit
over the past few months at least as a
topic of discussion where obviously we
still have troops all over the place
we're still working with countries that
are bombing and droning people what is
your vision for the US as a world power
especially you know in a world where
China and other regional actors or world
powers are starting to flex what what's
an Amash foreign policy look like we
need to be engaged with the world but
that doesn't mean we have to be at war
throughout the world so I'm not opposed
to bodies where countries from around
the world come and meet like the UN and
can engage and discuss thing that
doesn't mean that we should give those
bodies authority over US citizens to
decide laws for our people but it does
mean that it these can be positive
venues where countries can come together
and hash things out and work through
differences I think that kind of
dialogue is always important and it
would be a mistake for the u.s. to
retreat from the world in the sense of
not talking or engaging with other
countries we have to have that
engagement and if we don't have that
engagement if we don't have that
interaction if we don't have trade with
with other countries as well you will
have countries like China come in and
take advantage of the situation and
potentially present a threat to us down
the road so we want to have that
engagement as for Wars and having our
troops everywhere those things have to
be authorized and I think the American
people have to be firmly behind it with
a congressional authorization and so
often we've heard presidents say we're
gonna end this war or that war but
nothing ever happens what I would say if
I were president in the first first few
days of my presidency I would look at
these wars that are going on overseas
and I would tell Congress if I don't
think the war has an authorization I
would say to Congress
give me an authorization for this
conflict within 90 days if you don't do
that we're bringing the troops home and
force their hand on it and then if the
American people support engagement in
that war then they can authorize their
representatives and Senators to vote for
that for that engagement and and that's
how that's how that should be handled
can you talk about why what are your
qualifications to run the country you
know you're a five-term congressman but
you know is that enough what you know
how are you qualified to actually assume
the office of the presidency yeah and I
I'm sure you didn't mean to say run the
country because as we know that the
president is not running the country but
I think it's important that I do have a
background in Congress I've served nine
years in Congress
and I understand the problems and I
think I've uniquely defined and
identified the problems over the past
few years what I've talked about the way
Congress operates the way is a top-down
system and I wrote about the partisan
death spiral that's going on there
hasn't been a member of Congress who's
emphasized those points more and I think
has gotten to the bottom of what's
really hindering our system and causing
people to not feel represented at home
when you have a few people at the top
who control everything
of course people at home are gonna feel
like they don't have real representation
in Washington and and it also enhances
the partisanship because when people
can't fight on policy what they start
doing is fighting on personalities and
you get more partisan sniping you get
more sticking with your team because
there's nothing else to do you're not
actually working on crafty legislation
so when Pelosi says we're doing this you
stick with her because that's your team
or what McConnell says we're doing this
you stick with them and that's a really
dangerous environment and I recognize
that and I think I'm uniquely suited to
challenging that system because I've
shown in Congress my determination on
these things my willingness to go it
alone if I have to to stand up for
what's right I've been willing to break
from my party when I was a Republican
many times on many difficult issues
because we understood what was going on
and and we did in my office we did what
we we thought was right and I think I
think those are important considerations
I've also pushed for rules changes in
the house so for example I was able to
change the house rules to make the bills
we read to look more like track changes
in a Word document
so that people could more easily read
legislation because for a long time you
had people having to just do cross
references on the bills where you have
to go back and forth and at least for
the committee report portion of the
bills now you are getting them in more
of a track changes form it doesn't go
all the way through the process it
doesn't go as far as I would like
but I was at least able to get that
changed through and those are the kind
of ideas there are a lot of process
ideas that I think needs to come into
play if we want to fix this system and
most people are focused on substance and
I've been very focused on process over
the past nine years let's go back to
generational politics for a moment I
mean you essentially said Joe Biden is
too old to you know beep be an effective
president Donald Trump is much younger
and and show scattered thoughts and
whatnot you know Millennials and Gen Z
voters are less partisan and the older
you get the more likely are to just keep
voting for one party or the other there
are also the ones who are gonna be
paying for the twenty three twenty four
trillion dollar debt can you talk
specifically to younger Americans how
does having that much debt screw them
over and kind of beggar their future
well if they have that kind of debt they
have a very uncertain future because
there's no guarantee that our economic
system can sustain that kind of debt in
the future right now of course we've
been able to handle it we remain the
strongest economy in the world but
that's all not guaranteed things can
change in the future you could have a
situation where another country starts
to rise and it starts to gain prominence
and and its currency starts to become a
dominant currency and you could have
then a massive debt problem in this
country where things spiral out of
control there's massive inflation or
very high interest rates and the people
left holding the bag will be the next
generation who have to pay back all of
this debt and and can't spend the money
then on the things that they want to
spend on in the present younger voters
also care a lot about immigration ending
the drug war emptying prisons and
reducing economic inequality okay can we
go through these real quick what what is
your basic position on on immigration I
support immigration and I think we need
to fix our immigration system so that
people can come here lawfully right now
what we have is a system where millions
of people will come here unlawfully and
you probably have the same number of
people
arriving in the United States it's just
that they would be lawful and that would
be a benefit to our country because then
instead of hiding many of these people
would go and integrate into society in a
way that is beneficial to all of us it'd
be more likely for those who are
concerned about people learning English
or people assimilating into communities
they'd be much more likely to do so if
they come here lawfully and are welcomed
as lawful residents of the United States
and potentially lawful citizens of the
United States so we should we should do
that and I come from a family of
immigrants my parents are both
immigrants and they were welcomed here
to the United States my dad was welcomed
as a refugee and that I'm sure made a
big difference in his life and a big
difference in my mom's life in how they
integrated and how they felt about
America as a country and that was
instilled in me as a child where I
understood what a blessing it was to be
born in this country and how much better
off we have it than so many other
countries in the world this is the best
country on Earth and I I really sought
to preserve it and uphold our
constitutional system that's why I ran
for office so that we could preserve
this for the next generation would you I
mean would you be in favor of an
immigration policy that if is is
essentially you know if you want to come
here and work and live legally you can
as long as you're not as long as you
don't have communicable diseases or a
violent criminal past I think for the
most part yes yeah I mean anytime you
have a policy it's it's never laid out
that simply so you want to work through
all the details and make sure you've
covered all the bases but for the most
part yeah if someone wants to come to
the United States and work here and be a
resident of the United States we should
make that as open and possible as
weekend what what about the drug war at
the federal level obviously a lot of
drug policy at the state level but what
should the federal government's role be
and you know telling people what
substances they can or cannot use I
don't think the federal government
should have a role in that I believe
that should be left to the states states
can make those decisions and
and states are perfectly equipped to
make those decisions there's no reason
you should have one government the
federal government telling everyone what
to do and when you do that you also have
state laws now that conflict with the
federal law and you might even have
local laws that could have like - the
state laws so in some places like
Michigan for a while we had a huge
conflict where the City of Grand Rapids
had a different law than the state of
Michigan which had a different law than
the federal government and that's a
total mess so depending on which officer
approaches you you're in trouble in
different ways what's your vision in
terms of kind of economic mobility and
economic inequality you know it seems
that the spread between the richest
Americans and poorest Americans is is
growing in your mind is economic
opportunity dwindling in America and if
so how you know what what are the types
of policies as president you can support
or push that would make that better I
think there is a gap between the rich
and the poor that is widening and you
can see it in businesses you can see
that people who have professional skills
are often advancing while people with
blue-collar skills are being left behind
and some of that is due to automation
some of that is due to productivity
gains through technology and other
things and perhaps trade in some
instances too so we have to find ways to
make sure that people are educated I
think this starts with the education
system and these are mostly state level
issues use not federal issues but
finding ways for adults who are in
difficult circumstances to get education
and training in new fields I think is
really important but again it's not
something that has to happen at the
federal level it makes more sense at the
state level the needs of the state of
Michigan are going to be very different
from the needs of New Mexico or Idaho or
some other state or the state of New
York so we we have to allow states to
make more of those decisions and base it
on the needs of the the people there
what about environmental issues and
again you know keeping it kind of focus
on younger voters
I suspect maybe the ones that give you
the longest look you know most polls
show that Millennials Gen Z people
really care about things like climate
change is climate change a priority
would it be a priority and an Amash
presidency and how do you conceptualize
government action when it comes to
environmental issues it is really
important and I believe climate change
is happening I want to be clear about
that because you sometimes hear from
elected officials and it's it's not
clear where they stand on that I believe
there is climate change I believe it's
very important I believe that humans do
affect it and that we should take action
with respect to climate change but we
have to be smart about the actions we
take and some of the things we can do
for example would be to look into
further nuclear power and finding ways
to get nuclear power in this country
because it is a relatively safe form of
production and very low emissions
compared to other forms of energy there
are there's a lot of pushback about that
whenever you talk about nuclear power
but I think it's important to consider
it I also think we need to make sure
we're not subsidizing any particular
energy sources so to the extent there
are oil subsidies or any other subsidies
we should get those subsidies out of the
way and allow people in the market to
make decisions about how they how they
get their energy and then we need to
continue to make sure that we're
innovating as a country and that really
happens at the private sector level so
for individuals who are buying a product
if they want to have an energy-efficient
product go buy that product I I do my
best to try to buy energy-efficient
products I love the idea of electric
cars as much as I love you know a v8 and
manual transmission or you are famous
again right yeah I so I loved the idea
though of having electric vehicles I
love the idea of wind power and solar
power and other things I think that
private actors need to get more involved
and companies may need to make it more
of a priority and the companies
themselves
can get together and present their own
metrics and and present that to the
public there's no reason companies for
example couldn't show off all the time
about how environmentally friendly they
are with their products and then the
people who like that can go buy that
product and it would be a very high
proportion of the United States but what
I what I always warn people is we need
to have that balance if you put too many
regulations in place you may stifle
innovation in a way that actually hurts
the economy and hurts the climate
because if the economy goes bad people
stop caring about innovation as much I
mean when when you're really struggling
you're not as worried about the
energy-efficient refrigerator or vehicle
you're more worried about can you put
your food in something and can you get
to work you you don't worry about can't
will I pay
you're not thinking can I pay a few
hundred dollars more or a thousand
dollars more for this energy-efficient
model so we want to keep the economy
strong your your colleague congressional
colleague Alexandria Kaiser Cortez a
while back made a huge splash with the
green New Deal Joe Biden is he has
signed on to at least some version of
that you are not a supporter of the
green New Deal are you and if not what
what what is you know what's wrong with
it
well I haven't read the green New Deal
but from what I've heard about it it's a
lot of guidance and other things there
may be some parts of it that are okay in
terms of just providing guidance and
suggestions but but I haven't really
spent time with it and I could have
really answer the question effectively
okay well let's talk about your chances
of actually winning and a reception of
your announcement which has been you
know pretty extreme in many ways both at
least some in libertarian circles I
think there's a lot of enthusiasm
everywhere else not so much and we'll
talk about that in a second but you told
my colleague Matt Welch just the other
day that you wouldn't be running unless
you thought you could win realistically
what's the possible path for you to get
270 electoral votes well it depends on
what voters do my job is to get out
there and get the message to the people
I'm doing lots of interviews I'm talking
to journalists I'm talking to
delegates I'm talking to people around
the country doing video conferencing I'm
trying to get the message out there and
I believe that if you hear this message
for many months and then you can compare
and contrast me to the other candidates
you will see a big difference and you
will see that the more capable candidate
is the one running for the Libertarian
Party nomination and and serving as a
libertarian party candidate if I earn
that nomination so I think that's really
important just getting my face out there
getting media heads and trying to get
that message out there because I think
that it will be an appealing message at
the end of the day I think people just
want someone who's normal
honest practical and capable that's
that's what they want and when you look
at that criteria you you don't Donald
Trump doesn't fit the bill and Joe Biden
in most respects doesn't fit the bill so
I think there's a real opportunity here
and maybe this situation where we're all
working from home and and we can do all
these videoconferencing outreaches maybe
that will actually help get the message
out there
yeah well talk a bit about that because
not only you know as a libertarian or as
a third party candidate you're already
starting with you know a kind of support
deficit and all of that but now we're in
an age where it may not even be that you
can have rallies or you can't have you
know rallies of more than five people or
something how does that challenge you or
how does that how do you think that
gives you an opportunity these these
bizarre kind of you know how do you
campaign for president in any era of
social distancing well in the short run
I think it's an opportunity for me
because I don't have high name ID so if
Donald Trump goes anywhere in the
country people know who he is he can
hold a big rally Joe Biden for the most
part - I don't know that he's been
holding big rallies like that but he
could do it I have pretty low name ID so
I'm starting from scratch for me it's an
advantage to start on outreach in this
format where we're doing the video
conferencing where we are able to reach
out to people all digitally I think
that's an advantage as I grow my name
identification over time and
then once I built up enough name ID and
gotten my message out there enough we
can go from city to city and hold some
rallies so hopefully that will happen
later in the cycle but I think right now
this presents an opportunity let me give
you a couple of quotes and I'd like you
to respond to them these are people
responding to your announcement
George Conway a prominent nevertrump
Republican he's married to Kellyanne
conway who's in the White House
administration he said the only real
effect of maash could have in this
campaign is to enhance Trump's chances
this is a terrible idea what do you
think about that it's not based on any
evidence or math nobody has any real
evidence of this and the math is
impossible
people keep pretending that it's
actually possible to figure this out and
it's mathematically not possible because
there are so there's variables do you
think you I mean do you think you your
appeal you know I mean what or do you
think you're more likely to help you
know to say help button all right is
your support more likely to come from
disaffected Trump voters or disaffected
Biden voters so this is the way I look
at it and like I said it's
mathematically impossible to figure this
out because there are too many variables
there are a couple hundred million
voters in the United States potential
voters and there are you know infinite
preferences
so you know each voter has a different
set of preferences you've never you
never figure out what the what the
number of possibilities are you can't
figure out all the permutations on this
kind of thing and so to analyze it and
figure out who's going to vote for who I
don't know but what I would say
anecdotally my my instincts especially
interacting with people and talking to
people over the past year or so are that
if if people are worried about potential
Trump voters who might go to Joe Biden
or might go to me what I would say is
this if you look at voters who are low
put it this way Republicans
who don't like Trump but are still
voting for Trump versus Republicans who
don't like Trump but are voting for
Biden which group do you think is better
I would say that the bigger group is
Republicans who don't like Trump but are
voting for Trump that's probably the
pool that I will pull more people from
anecdotally but again we can't figure
that out nobody knows the answer who do
you think you'll will you actualize her
or kind of activate people who are not
interested in politics to do something
and this was Ron Paul who is a mentor
figure too in many ways you know he in
2008 and 2012 he seemed to bring people
into politics who otherwise didn't care
he wasn't necessarily making people
switch is that your goal or do you think
is that the thing that you need to do in
order to be a full of real force in this
election I think there are some
Republicans who will vote for me there
are some Democrats who will vote for me
and then there's a large swath of voters
which is probably the plurality of the
United States who aren't closely
affiliated with either of the parties
and I think many of them often don't
vote and it gives them an opportunity to
vote for someone they actually want to
be in the White House so it's possible
it changes that dynamic in a very big
way but we can't know until we try it I
think everyone spent so much time trying
to figure out what's going to happen
instead of just trying it and seeing
what happens and I wouldn't try it if I
didn't believe it was winnable when you
look at the groups of voters out there
and the opportunities it is a winnable
thing and we should try that and we
should give people more options on the
ballot and at the end of the day if you
don't want to vote for someone don't
vote for that person nobody is required
to vote for me nobody is required to
vote for the other two candidates either
so just vote for the one you want and
that's the person who will win if they
if they get the most votes you know to
talk about polarization you you left up
the Republican Party partly because I
obviously disagree with the way the
Republican Party is going on things like
spending immigration of you know
military interventions but also you said
you left because you didn't want
be party to a partisan death spiral and
kind of tribalist loyalties that were
destroying the country what is the and
and obviously I agree with you Matt
Welch and I co-wrote a book called the
Declaration of Independence about how
independent voters are the single
largest group it's about 40% of voters
identify at least when polled as
independents but to talk about this
tribalism in your district in in
Michigan
you went from winning re-election by 60%
to when you started criticizing Donald
Trump suddenly you're getting all kinds
of flak and when you became an
independent I mean you're facing a
challenge where you probably heard in
many polls wouldn't win it's not a sign
that tribalism is actually alive and
well I mean it might be ugly and stupid
but it seems to be a major major force
in in the way politics operates well
just correct you on that point
okay in my district when you when you
talk about this race the polling did not
actually show that I would be in trouble
there was no polling on a general
election no public polling on a general
election that had me as an independent
there was there was no such polling done
and all of our polling had me in the
lead or very competitive at the top of a
three-way race so we felt very confident
in this race and I was able to raise
everyone in the in the race until I
decided to pause my fundraising I think
that when you look at what happened in
this district my favorability went up
when I became an independent because
people are sick of the two parties and
they're sick of all the fighting and
they want someone who's going to go to
Washington and represent them and stop
worrying about the partisans partisan
nonsense so I think people are ready to
abandon these parties and move toward a
system that is more independent but in
the meantime I do think we need a
competitor to these two parties I don't
think it's going to happen overnight I
can win this district as an independent
but many other people would not dare to
try it because it is a complicated thing
to run without that kind of support
behind you an apparatus like a
party right so most people aren't that
comfortable doing that so in the mean
time in the short run I'd say in the
next decade or so you have to have a
strong competitor and that competitor
can be the Libertarian Party yeah two
two quick questions one is have you are
you not running for re-election for your
congressional seat now that's right yeah
I'm running for one seat at a time so
I'm running for the White House so
here's here's a question to reason
obviously has a lot of fans and they who
are registered with the Libertarian
Party you have not yet won the
nomination there that that will be held
in May at their nominating convention
what is your specific message to
Libertarian Party members and
particularly those delegates there's
about a thousand of them who will decide
the Libertarian Party candidate why
should it be you as opposed to people
who have been laboring in the fields of
the lp for four years now well I've been
a libertarian my whole life
a small L libertarian and I brought that
to Congress and served in Congress as a
small L libertarian for more than nine
years and was able to bring those
principles to the table and to fight for
libertarian principles I became an
independent because I realized that
these two parties weren't cutting it and
I thought genuinely that I could make
the Republican party a more libertarian
party because when I first joined the
Republican Party they espouse some
principles at least on paper that were
closer to libertarianism than what we
see today so I thought I could change
the party I became an independent and
wanted to change the system that way I'm
coming to the Libertarian Party at a
later stage than I'd like but at the
same time I've been a libertarian a
smaller libertarian my whole life I'm
going to work to earn their support over
the next few weeks I'm going to spend
time reaching out to delegates and
reaching out to the party to make sure
that they feel comfortable with me and
I'm committed to the party so yes I'm
just starting in the party but I'm going
to serve in Congress as a libertarian
I'm going to change my ID to the
libertarian
I'm committed to working with the party
and making the party a major competitor
and not just in this cycle but in future
cycles as well you came to Congress as
part of a tea party wave back in the
what 2010 elections do you think the
combination of the both the lockdown
you know the corona virus pandemic and
and the spending that is coming out of
that you know do you think that's
capable of creating a new set of
political moments movements like the
financial crisis did both the Tea Party
and the Occupy movement came out of that
do you think something like that is
going to happen or might happen coming
out of this particular situation we're
in right now I think it's possible I
hope it's channeled in the right
direction some of it seems to be
protesters who are you know rallying for
Trump and if they're rallying for Trump
I think they're missing the point a
little bit a lot of the things the
states are doing for example that
restricts rights are at the behest of
the administration through its own
guidance it might not be firmly pushed
by the administration but it's the
administration's guidance that is
leading to it so I think we have to be
careful and and channel it in the right
direction we need to channel our
frustration toward making sure that our
rights are protected generally and not
into some kind of partisan message about
one party's good and the other party's
bad and you can see that also in the
economic relief package you can't just
blame one party for it so we can't have
it be a partisan message again this mean
it was truly you know what the Patriot
Act which and actually the tarp bailouts
this was almost passed unanimously right
that's right with very few exceptions
there were maybe a few of us who
submitted a no vote on the record like I
don't know how many but it was you can
count them on your fingers right and it
was Republicans and Democrats working
together to bail out the big companies
help those who are well-connected very
quickly and then leave millions of other
people behind who really need the help
so
if if we can channel it in the right
direction I think we can have a movement
that is actually a libertarian movement
that can they can upset this status quo
and push back against these two parties
you know presidents often or
presidential candidates typically talk
about their their biography as a form of
political expression you mentioned your
parents are immigrants your father was a
refugee from Palestine is that correct
yeah that's right okay and you have kids
you know so I mean you're first
generation born in America what do you
know how do how do you see your your
personal history as somehow illustrating
something that is you know that is
meaningful about America and what are
what are the hopes and dreams for the
country that your kids will live in
other than paying off all of the bills
because of your you know of the
legislation that your colleagues decided
they should they should be paying for
well the one thing that gives me hope is
that America has always risen to the
task so we've had a lot of challenges in
the past there are times where things
look grim or where we took steps that
look like there were steps backward and
we've come through it and found ways to
expand Liberty and sometimes it can take
decades it might not happen overnight
but we found ways to move forward and
improve the country I think in most
respects when it comes to our laws the
the major laws affecting our rights you
have more Liberty in a great sense today
than you did before now you have a
government that has consolidated a lot
of power in other ways but there are
also a lot of advancements I mean you
have for example you didn't even have
gay marriage not it wasn't that long ago
you don't have gay marriage in this
country it wasn't that long ago frankly
that black Americans were treated as
truly second-class citizens with with
different rights the way they were
treated and there's still discrimination
in this country and there are still
problems that we need to move forward
for a whole bunch of communities
including black Americans but there are
there have been gains
in the past decades and we'll keep
moving forward so I have hope for the
next generation my parents coming here
as immigrants they instilled in me a
love for this country and a love for the
opportunity it provides that every
person can come here or be born here and
have a chance to make it and to set
their own course for their life they
don't have to have the government set
the course for them or have the right
last name or the right religion or right
background anyone can do it here and
that doesn't mean that there aren't
disparities and disadvantages there are
although all of those things and in fact
my parents face disadvantages as well
coming here as immigrants and and face
discrimination in some ways as well even
though they don't they don't talk about
it that much frankly but they do they
certainly did face some discrimination
when they were here and when they first
came here and so there are opportunities
here and they taught me to love this
country and love what it stands for and
and I'll keep fighting for what this
country is about which is the ability to
interact with others freely and make the
decisions for your own life two final
quick questions first is you mentioned
discrimination what is the role of the
government in remedying discrimination
do you have a general theory about that
yes the federal government has an
important role in remedying
discrimination and in fact the
Fourteenth Amendment is really
structured around that particularly with
respect to how the states might apply
their laws and the Fourteenth Amendment
is my favorite amendment to the
Constitution because I think at its core
is the literary summarize would you
summarize the 14th Amendment for those
of us who are English majors and/or at
math well importantly the Fourteenth
Amendment talks about due process and
equal protection and at the core of
Liberty and libertarianism is this idea
of the rule of law and the rule of law
really entails these ideas of due
process and equal protection
particularly the idea of equality before
the law that every person should be
treated equally under the law and so I
think that there is a major role for the
federal government to play in protecting
individual rights and in fact that's why
the Fourteenth Amendment exists and it
is my favorite amendment to the
Constitution because I think it really
embodies the idea of Liberty the best of
any of the amendments even though there
are great there's a great case to be
made for the First Amendment and the
Second Amendment and and several other
amendments about the idea of Liberty
I think the Fourteenth Amendment really
embodies it best so the Fourteenth
Amendment apply essentially applies the
Bill of Rights or the Constitution the
Federal Constitution to the states the
the rights that are guaranteed under
that and I keep saying two more
questions I actually do only have two
more decision and I guess the the one is
you are anti-abortion if I'm correct can
you explain what how that would play out
what would your priorities be in an
Amash administration in terms of
abortion policy throughout the country
I'm pro-life under present pro-life and
I know that there's a split even within
the Libertarian Party for example on
that issue and and and I recognize that
and and I don't know which which side is
bigger right now than the other but but
it's definitely a divide within a
libertarian party and it's a divide
within the country there's no doubt
about that I mean it's a major divide
between the Republican Party and the
Democratic Party what that means though
is that very little legislation is going
to get through that changes it in the
near term I've always said that the life
movement if you're pro-life the best way
to advance it is through society through
methods of engagement and discussion
conversation and activism so I've been
involved in in pro-life organizations
that try to change it from the outside
not through the legislative process but
try to change hearts and minds and and
explain the issue to people so you
wouldn't be calling you wouldn't be
calling for a repeal of Roe vs. Wade or
or you would not be calling for a
federal law that would ban abortion at
you know across the country well to be
clear I think most progressive scholars
also I think roe v wade is his bad law
right they might agree with the outcome
but they would likely
agree with the way it was drafted as an
opinion so my job as a president is to
execute the laws it's not to write the
laws the Congress is going to write that
the right to loss and I think it's very
important as part of being a president
that you be humble in your role that you
have some humility about the process and
your role in the process and I want to
leave it to Congress to make those
decisions but I'm very clear about my
position on it I'm pro-life and I I
support pro-life legislation and have
supported pro-life legislation but as
for what comes to my desk the probably
the most you're going to get is
something to defund abortion providers
not provide federal funding for abortion
providers or abortions and I think most
people in a libertarian party for sure
but a lot of Americans can understand
that concern that in an issue that's
that controversial you should keep the
federal government out of the funding
yeah whether it's local government or
private effort to to fund those things
or or what have you that's a different
story and communities can decide that
individuals can decide that but at the
federal level it seems wrong and it is
wrong to have the federal government
involved in such a controversial
practice okay okay I have finally
reached my absolute last question which
is what are you gonna pick as a campaign
song
and I want to kind of make it even
harder on you because you are from
Michigan you're proud of Michigan you
went to Michigan University of Michigan
twice I look forward to you getting a
PhD from that mediocre institution but
you know pick a campaign song and it
doesn't have to be a Michigan band and
if so I'm gonna suggest you go with Iggy
and the Stooges I want to be your dog
but representative Amash what what is
your campaign sigh you know I knew you
were gonna ask me this I had heard that
this was gonna come up and I don't I
don't have to say for you I don't know
you know I I've thought through some of
the people and and music but it's just
it's just hard to come up with something
I sometimes I'm at home and I'll hear
something and I'll say to my kids you
know that's a good campaign song but I
did
I can't think of one on this pile this I
have to admit that Trump by I don't know
if it was his official song but he would
play you can't always get what you want
by the rolling chances
well if that's kind of inspired and I'm
assuming Biden is something like when
I'm 64 because it would be aspirational
for him to merely be 64 but congressman
thank you for taking the time to talk to
us we will be checking in with you as
you progress across the you know looking
to get the the libertarian nomination
and we'll see how all of that goes
thanks very much for your time thanks so
much